- How I like to do it—like,
I like to get jiggy at the line.
Man, let's ride with it.
Oh, 'scuse me.
- Stop the hate.
Appreciate.
- It's been a fun year, man.
- Yes, it has.
Very fun.
And we gonna win on a bang.
Don't worry about it.
I'm not worried.
♪♪♪
- What do you know?
The Patriots are in
the Super Bowl, Simms.
- Oh, real shocker, Lefkoe.
- You know who's not?
- Yeah.
Your Eagles?
- No.
- That shirt?
That's definitely not
in the Super Bowl.
- I kinda think there's
a little Saints flair to it.
- Oh, is that right?
- Right? Don't I look like I could be
walkin' down the street
with a marching band?
- You're gonna start hatin'
on the Saints right away?
- No, I didn't, I didn't do anything.
- You brought them up without—
we were trying to talk about—
- They were one of
the four teams that played.
- We were talking about the Rams
and the Patriots.
- I wanna say this.
- Yes.
- To Saints fans—
- Right.
- What happened to you is a travesty.
I wish that upon no fanbase.
And this is complete sincerity.
That was nonsense,
and I apologize.
- Yeah.
- I wanna just
get that out there.
- I get you.
That was a brutal call.
- I will say, though,
that the Super Bowl
does feel weird
from this aspect.
2018 felt like Mahomes-Brees,
Chiefs-Saints the whole year.
- Yeah.
- The Rams had their moments.
The Patriots always
have their moments.
- Right.
- But I felt like it
was all leading
towards Chiefs-Saints.
- Yeah.
- And I really wanna say—
- Because we made it
about two people
Mahomes and Brees.
That's all it was about.
- Oh, you're upset about this?
- Well, it's just, like—listen, that's
the matchup I wanted to see.
- OK, good.
- I get you there.
But I also picked the Patriots
and Rams
to win those football games
cuz I said
"Hmm, their teams are greater,
even though we have
this sex appeal matchup at the
quarterback position we like."
- Well, then let's say this,
though, for real.
We have loved Rodgers
for a long time.
- Yes.
- You are someone that appreciates
great quarterback play.
- No doubt.
- What we witnessed this year
with Patrick Mahomes
cannot be forgotten.
And to everyone out there
that's saying
"We have all these years,
guaranteed," look at Dan Marino.
None of this stuff
is guaranteed.
- Nothing.
- We don't know if Mahomes
is gettin' back here.
We don't know if Tyreek Hill's
gonna be
at this speed the rest of his career.
- Right.
- We don't know about
Travis Kelce.
What we witnessed:
5,000 yards, 50 touchdowns.
I just wanted to give it more love.
- We should.
- Because I fell in love
with my favorite quarterback
in the NFL, Patrick Mahomes.
- I mean, I can't even
believe it.
It's blasphemy. Get outta here.
- Patrick Mahomes.
- Sorry, Aaron, we're gonna get
a new host next year.
Don't worry, buddy.
But—
- Wax poetic about Mahomes.
- I mean, it was a special,
special year.
- It was special!
- Patrick Mahomes, in this day
and age, for what he did
I mean, guys like Peyton Manning
and Tom Brady
you know, 50 touchdown passes,
they didn't do that
until they were
in the middle of their career.
- They already had a Masters,
a doctorate
in the quarterback position.
- Exactly right.
This guy throws for 5,000 yards
50 touchdowns, has his first year
as a true starter, right.
And all the teams they faced
every week knew that
that was the No. 1 thing
they had to stop
and he still delivered week
after week after week.
- He's amazing.
- He is amazing.
- I told you guys in like
Week 10 or 11
the Patriots are gettin'
to the Super Bowl.
You're gonna think it's not
happening, it's happening.
This is like if you took
Tim Duncan and LeBron James
like, their streaks
and, like, put them together
and then you added Popovich
and then, like, then,
like, Roger Federer.
- It's—hey.
It's—
- And then the Yankees
in the '90s.
Like, it's crazy.
- We will never see anything
like this again
in the history of the NFL.
Bill Belichick is by far
the greatest coach
in the history of the sport.
I don't think that's even, like,
a point to argue anymore.
Tom Brady, of course,
what he's doing
the sustained greatness
is amazing.
But the big thing I wanna say
to everybody out there
about the New England Patriots
is this.
Stop the hate.
Appreciate.
OK?
You're not gonna see
this very often.
This is a rare thing.
And as much as we all wanna
hate the Patriots
and I worked for them,
and I know some of these guys
and I have weeks where I go
"Damn, I'm sick of hearin'
about 'em.
I hope they lose this week."
It's still phenomenal
what they do.
- It's amazing.
- This is the era of salary cap,
free agency.
The league is supposed to be
close and competitive.
I know.
I'm goin' off because this is
how amazing it is.
- No, it's real.
It's real.
- It's supposed to be close
and competitive.
They made the rules so we
would have different teams
be at the top every year
and the only thing
that's been consistent
is the New England Patriots
for the whole 21st century.
It's been the New England
Patriots, and I just—
I'm amazed by it.
- Yeah.
- It's like two 49er dynasties.
I mean, that's what it is.
I mean, it's amazing.
It's two Steeler dynasties.
- Belichick called me yesterday
to ask for advice.
- He did?
- I told him to relax.
- What, he wanted to know
what sweater to wear
for next week, what sweatshirt?
- Damn it.
- I gotta cut these sleeves off.
- It's Landon Collins. You're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
Uh, that's it.
- In the process of doing
this show
I think we've made
some special friendships
with players and former players.
- Definitely, right.
And I think T.O. and Chad Johnson
are at the top of the list.
- I mean, no doubt about it.
- They're our buddies.
- They, like, wanted to hang out
with us when we were in L.A.
- And we were like,
"Chill, chill, we gotta go."
- "We got plenty of time, seriously."
By the way, they're gonna be
in Atlanta
so email
simmsandlefkoe@gmail.com
if you're gonna make it there.
They will be there.
But I'm on Twitter.
- Yeah.
- And I see Chad Johnson go,
"I wanna do my own show
where we got a wide receiver
and I get to work on him."
- Right.
- This is that show.
We got Chad Johnson and T.O.
and Mr. Ridley outta Georgia,
who's gonna be maybe
a first-round pick
in the NFL draft.
- What's Mr. Ridley's first name?
- Riley.
Nailed it under pressure.
- And his brother
is Calvin Ridley.
- Nailed it under pressure.
- You almost choked there.
But yes, this is your big
audition, T.O. and Ochocinco.
- Yeah.
- Show us what you got.
But seriously, they are gonna
show us what they got.
- They got it.
- Here's two guys that I know
through my just knowing
people in football.
Yeah, they're ultra-talented.
Yeah, it's great touchdown
dances and all that.
But they are obsessed
with their craft.
They were obsessed
with route-running
and NFL receivers
still go work with them
to clean up their game.
- And here's why.
- You see I got the shirt
tucked in, right?
- That don't mean nothing to me.
- You know what that means?
- No, I don't know what it means.
- I got this shirt
tucked in, right?
- What's that mean?
- That means you learned how
to put your shirt in your pants.
- Listen, when you go on a job
don't you go
with your shirt tucked in?
Cuz you mean business, right?
Hello.
I am Chad Johnson.
I am here with my good friend
and Hall of Fame
receiver Terrell Owens
and up-and-coming
draft prospect
one of the best receivers
in the nation, Riley Ridley.
- Riley Ridley stepping up!
- Touchdown, Riley Ridley.
- Touchdown, Georgia!
- What do you feel like your
best asset is as a receiver?
- Right now, I'm physical.
- OK.
- I'm physical, more physical
than any receiver
going into the draft.
I'm more physical than any DB.
- So that's something that
you don't have to work on.
So now, you gotta worry about—
work on the finesse part of the game.
- So you got T: muscle.
- Right.
- Physical.
- Physical, get through you,
and then you have my skill set
where it's completely opposite.
"Don't touch me."
How I like to do it—like,
I like to get jiggy at the line.
Man, let's ride with it.
Oh, 'scuse me.
And I need all this space.
- My coach said—
he said this to me
because he knew
I liked basketball.
- Right.
- And this is what clicked for me.
He said you have to treat
the defensive back
like you're playin' one-on-one.
If you playin' one-on-one
and you tryin' to get by me
what are you gonna do?
- I'm gonna make some moves.
- You gotta make me move.
- Right.
- Same thing with every route,
pretty much
cuz I'm tryin'
to score a bucket.
- That's what I'm tryin' to get at.
I'm here.
I'm gonna give you two steps
and then I'm gettin'
right into this.
- OK, show me.
- So I'm here, and I'm gone.
- OK.
Initially when you came off
the ball, boom-boom
you kinda
got wide a little bit.
Try to stay a little—
Try to engage them a little bit
more, you know what I mean?
- Absolutely, mhmm.
- So I like what you did.
Boom-boom-boom, here,
then kinda get into him.
Invite him.
And when you here, you wanna
show that acceleration
like you about to go deep.
- Deep.
- Then you stop.
My problem was, when I used
to get it going in my breaks
I used to—yeah, I used to have
these flappers right here.
Then my coach told me
I had to be a drummer boy,
you know what I mean?
Be a drummer boy.
Then when I did, when I did it here
transition, it's in
and out of my breaks quick.
- Right.
- We're trying to get you
to become a salesman
before you actually a salesman.
I do a dig route based off
a, off a comeback stance.
I call it send the dude
to the Gatorade.
I'm gonna send him
So, just say—
come here, come in here.
Just say the ball is in there.
- Right.
- The ball is in there.
And I got a dig route.
So this is what I'm gonna do.
Boom, boom,
I'm gonna get him right here.
Aha.
I—oooh.
I'mma send him
to the Gatorade.
- No doubt.
- All this right here is open.
Cuz as soon as you nod
that way, he gone.
- And very seldom on deep balls
do you just blow by a dude.
That ain't happenin'.
- Yeah.
- That ain't happenin'
unless you just beat
somebody off the line.
You just gas him.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, you got to be
goddamn Tyreek Hill or some—
That's a different ballgame.
- Randy is one of those guys.
- Randy.
- There's a few guys.
- Yeah, Randy, you see
the mailbox like—
- When he throw that hand up—
- It's really over.
- Not, not everybody is like that.
He's freakish.
Just freakishly fast,
you know what I mean
to the point that he start
coming off the line
and he already
sticking his hands up.
Right,
he's sticking his hands up.
- DB five yards away,
he gonna throw his hand up.
It's a bunch of receivers
in the NFL.
There's 32 teams.
There's a No. 1
on every team.
- Right.
- What's the difference in each
No. 1
and the rest of the receivers
on the team?
It's something about that dude
that makes him special.
It's something about Odell
that makes him different
than the rest of the Giants receivers.
- Right.
There's something about AB
that makes him special.
Something about Julio.
You got to go out wherever you go,
and when you get there
there gotta be something
about f--king Ridley
that makes him special.
- Exactly.
- That separates him
from everybody else.
- No doubt.
- Whether it's the way you work
whether it's your hands,
whether it's your feet
whether it's your routes,
whether it's you
being consistent,
gotta be something. One!
Ain't gotta be
a bunch of things.
It's one thing about Floyd
that makes him great.
There's a f--kin'
million boxers!
- Yeah.
- You not gonna hit me.
I'mma hit you whenever I want.
So as a receiver, you find
whatever that niche about you
that makes you special,
it's a wrap.
through this on your own,
you know what I'm sayin'
and have great people around you
and willing to help you,
it's amazing.
- And Calvin Ridley,
if you see this
I will lock you up, period.
- [Laughing]
- Period.
- No, you ain't finna to lock
nobody up, dawg.
Nobody.
- Check my resume.
- What a year for
"Somebody & Lefkoe."
We tried something new.
Went out and met a lotta new friends
and we actually made some money.
But you know that the Super Bowl
is not just about
pickin' the Rams
or the Patriots.
There's hundreds of prop bets
about commercials and dogs
and the national anthem,
so I'm uppin' the stakes.
$500.
I found some of my old friends
and we're laying 'em
on the props.
We are here at the subway
with the Patriots legend,
Steve Grogan.
Scratch that.
Ira, my good friend.
You're so spoiled
with this Patriots team.
- Nine in 18 years,
it's incredible.
- I'm excited about prop bets.
Here's one for you.
It's a spicy one.
Will Jim Nantz and Tony Romo
say the phrase "Hotlanta"?
- No!
Not in February.
- The favorite is "no."
You're goin' with the favorite?
- I'm goin' with the favorite.
- I don't care what the odds are.
- We're putting $500 on "no,"
no "Hotlanta."
We are back, lockin’ it up
with the legend, Dave.
Super Bowl prop bet, boy it’s a good one.
- It's a good one.
It’s hairy, it’s furry,
and it slobbers.
We’re doing over/under,
not for the game,
over/under 5.5 commercials
during the Super Bowl
that will have dogs in them.
This is a legitimate bet.
- Who the hell bets on dogs
in the Super Bowl?
- So I need your help.
We're currently betting on dogs
in the Super Bowl.
So over/under 5.5
commercials with dogs.
- It's the craziest thing
anyone's ever asked me.
So I'm gonna say under.
I'm not feelin'
the dogs this year.
- Super Bowl prop bet.
Gladys Knight singing
the national anthem.
Over 1:46 or under 1:46?
- It's gonna go over.
- You're sure?
- Yes, it's gonna go over.
- How come?
- It takes a long time
for them to sing good.
- It does.
Do you have any pipes?
- Pipes? Sure.
- Let me, "aah."
You got any?
- Yes.
- The Dragon.
He's the best, legitimately.
Forget the prop bets.
Forget the other Somebodies.
Allie has been the king
the entire time.
Playoffs, not so much.
Allie the Mush.
But we can flip it
in the Super Bowl
and make all our money back.
Patriots favored by a point-and-a-half
over the Rams in Atlanta.
- In Atlanta.
- Atlanta.
- I didn't wanna go
against Tom last week
but I told you if he won
we were goin' with him
in the Super Bowl.
It didn't matter who was
comin' on the other side.
I like him against the Rams,
even though they got a tough D.
I like Tom Brady
to pick 'em apart.
- An Allie lock.
- Absolutely.
- I like it.
I would go Patriots too.
- My man.
- It's been a fun year, man.
- Yes, it has.
Very fun.
And we gonna win on a bang.
Don't worry about it.
I'm not worried.
I like, I like Tom Brady
in the Super Bowl.
I'm convincing myself again?
- Yeah, yeah.
I need your insight on
another prop bet that I found.
- OK, gotcha.
I need your insight on
another prop bet that I found.
- OK, gotcha.
- There is apparently prop bets
for all of the CBS anchors
and who they're gonna pick
in the game.
- What kind of blazer
are they gonna wear?
- No, cuz they wear
the same blazer every week.
One of them is Phil Simms.
- Uh-oh.
- Do you know him?
- I do know him, yes.
- OK.
Apparently it's minus-120
Patriots, minus-110 Rams.
Let's just figure it out
with him now
and go make a billion dollars.
- Call him, call him up.
Figure it.
Just, you gotta worry
about, like
Jimmy the Leg, who might come
and break your leg
once he finds out
you're cheatin' the system
or something.
- Well, I got a guy.
- You got a guy?
He's got a guy, too.
- The thing I worry about, is
I feel like Phil
would tell me the Patriots now
and then suddenly be like,
"Sorry, Adam
I watched some film,
and now I'm goin' Rams."
- Well, I mean, yeah,
it's too early in the week.
I don't think,
he would know right now
but I do think—
- Damn. This was a foolproof plan!
- Early, I mean, Phil Simms,
he knows Belichick
played under him for a long time
with the New York Giants.
I would think he'd be favoring
the New England Patriots.
In fact, I think you gotta be
crazy not to be favoring
the New England Patriots
right now, right?
- Oooh. I am gonna call my bookie.
For Simms.
- Peace out, homies.
- I am Lefkoe, and here are some
bloopers that we haven't seen.
So we're going to look dumb,
and here they are.
- Hello!
We are acc—why am I yelling?
I'm not gonna yell this time.
I didn't wanna yell.
That's why I went really calm
the last time.
- OK, but you're a yeller.
You have a big f--kin' mouth.
Be Adam Lefkoe.
What are you gonna, f--kin' be
somebody else now?
Let's go.
- We took our act on the road
to take on the Forty-Ninles.
The Ninles.
- The Ninles.
- Amendment 1 and Amendment 2.
- Aaron Rodgers, Kyle Shanahan.
We'll figure out our amendments.
Vikings could've lost that game
to the 49ers.
Green, Green Bay—
God bless you, and God bless
Aaron Rodgers.
- Yes.
- That guy really
strung together
some winning seasons,
huh, Simms?
- Wow, hey, I mean, I'm too—
I can't remember
what exactly I was gonna say.
- We built your franchise.
- Well, I mean, Parcells
didn't...s--t.
- Got him.
Peace, bro.
- Matchmaker, matchmaker,
make me a match.
- You're absurd.
- Hey, where's the pizza?
I'm Don Corleone.
I need to shave.
I'm five minutes old.
That's what they call a gyro?
That's how you say it? Gyro?
♪♪♪
No way.
Negative, Ghost Rider.
Negative, Ghost Rider?
Negative, Ghost Rider!
The pattern is full!
Negative, Ghost Rider.
The pattern is full.
[Singing in Spanish]
Simms and Lefkoe,
the players' show
makin' you feel better, man.
- That's what I'm talkin'
about, man.
- Sorry, I didn't tell you
I was gonna—
- Damn!
- I got excited!
Well, you were wrong.
You said Friday.
- Ooh ooh ooh!
- Don't touch me.
[Laughing]
Punch Big Ben in the leg!
Kick him in the d--k!
- [Laughing]
- How would he procure
such saltwater taffy?
- I don't know what "procure"
means
so you'll have
to explain that to me.
- [Laughing]
- How did he obtain the saltwater taffy?
- Hold on one second.
[Laughing]
For Simms.
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-key-O-E—
- Man.
He's the K-O-E. He'll learn
how to spell his name
on the next episode
of "Simms & Lefkoe: The Show."
Till then, we'll have him in the
back, learning how to spell.
- What just happened?